[Musique]
cet été une vague de puritanisme semble
déferler sur certaines plages corses et
à prix moyen de se baigner tout le monde
est à poil
alors il faudrait savoir ce qu'on va
faire les en axe où c'est vraiment pour
prendre du soleil intégralement et
d'autres un peu pour se distinguer de
retour vous ne faites pas ça aussi un
peu par provocation au nom du tout du
tout pourtant dès lors un dilemme se
pose doit-on au nom de la morale cacher
ses seins que l'on ne saurait voir
et en le faisant éloignée une certaine
catégorie de touristes ou bien fermer
les yeux et récolter les devises qu'ils
apportent
nous avons refusé le nudisme sur les
plages de dépit pourtant il se pratique
je sais je sais qu'elle se pratique plus
ou moins oui on joue aux gendarmes et
aux voleurs
l'enjeu 500 fonds d'amande mais la
maréchaussée bon enfant moi même j'ai
résolu le problème je suis retourné au
village j'ai acheté quatre lots aux
vainqueurs de la bonne de la peinture la
ville verte pour pas des nantais avec la
nature et j'en ai plein droit des hommes
et une femme bien sûr l'exposition de
corps nus dont certains il faut bien
l'avouer ne sont pas des modèles
d'académie peut choquer les farouches
défenseurs du maillot une pièce
la solution est simple il existe déjà
pourquoi ne pas la généraliser par ci
par là
en réservant certains coins de coteau
naturiste avec pancartes à l'appui
mettant en garde les visiteurs sur ce
qui les attend
et dès ce moment là chacun devrait y
trouver son compte l'économie insulaire
la vertu des gens sages et l'épiderme
des naturistes qui préfère le soleil à
la peinture
[Musique]